today I'll show everything's going to be
nut but x-rated man that's right and
when we talk about x-rated on show like
fat man on Batman we're not talking
about pornography we're talking about
the x-men universe all day long here on
5 minute
who's that men on that man welcome to
Batman Batman I'm Kevin I'm mark barnard
all right man we got X news for you man
cross your fingers
this news is the effects is it XXX why
don't you come out man not too Vin
Diesel one either wow wow wow went well
Nick
snikt snikt Anthony they have a net vamp
it disappears here and then black
disappears over there this random
strangers get wadded in the face some
people will never know my agony that's
my knowledge some people never know but
ended they called me Nightcrawler in the
Munich circus goodness pants and Sansa
BAM damn could you remember that was a
gold standard at one point it really was
the opening sequence of that movie all
of x2 was like oh my god it'll never get
better than this and it's gotten way
better in a bad opening sequence is
phenom and that's good for a good long
while
yeah didn't know what that's what these
all should be like it's truly could you
remember back in the day to movie could
stand 20 years by itself like a Star
Wars and now it's just like it will pay
out a couple years yeah yeah I got a
sudden now every Marvel movie opens with
like here's some famous [ __ ] you know
dialed back to 20 but we're all like
take my money I was the old man turn
young at what point will we see the
young Stallone cousin 'you know and they
got the footage for it we will have to
get young stallone young Ving Rhames and
young michelle yeoh just rocking a
spaceship somewhere for the guardians
say yeah um really the students can be
[ __ ] oh my god I didn't know we were
doing impressions I would have brushed
up on my Stallone as well I would have
called the brow and be like can you work
us solos I made your workshop uh
Stallone impression doo-doo-doo-doo
that's pretty good all right action news
hit me with the X [ __ ] what he got they
are making a new mutants movie did you
know had a Josh Boone's that yeah The
Fault in Our Stars game II was here in
this very house we've recorded a podcast
once what yeah for father was a very
nice kid but he was at one point talking
about mega spider-man
before spider-man went to Disney and
stuff like that and this one I I look
forward to his take on a particularly
because it sounds very old-school he's
using almost all the old characters from
issue one of New Mutants he's doing the
cannonball Walter named Danny moon star
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's pretty dope man
that's cool so that is uh who's gonna
play ball spades well there's been two
castings has been Maisie Williams is
playing will Spain a man like that girl
she's one doesn't [ __ ] Thrones my god
her Scottish werewolf yes please and
Anya Keller joy who was in the witch and
split oh he called Morgan that came out
that nobody saw directed by Ridley Scott
son is playing Indiana rescue Tintin
who's that that is magic also pure clear
recipe things um you know Colossus his
sister oh that's why I know that name
yes Wow so what'd she have metal skin
she's got that [ __ ] like metal like
arm band thinks gonna wanna mister guy's
name again magic ok source written yeah
ring any bells
how many bells for you nurse there's a
bunch of teleportation magic [ __ ] Oh God
by it I'm sure it's true but I just say
yeah I don't know the guy all right over
there never seen that before my life no
the actress tone familiar with her work
yeah yes no mutants
I'm all for I'm I started collecting
that from issue on when I first when
they someone who used to come mail to my
house and a brown envelope
Neru have been that porn version of good
mail because it was small you don't so
yeah man bring it give it to me and
who's doing a studio thing is Fox me
[ __ ] a cuz you know Fox has got to
keep that x-men license fresh print
money with it and they got to keep
making these movies or the rights will
revert back to Marvel yeah but look I'm
glad to keep making moves as long as
they keep making them like Logan and
Deadpool and keep making X movies
they're fine over Disney I'd Marvel
Studios they got enough to work with
indeed
so yeah that's coming April 13th 2013
2018 2018 we're not going to go back in
time this is a Bryan Singer expert can I
go back in time 2018 so over a year from
now yeah
or one year from now less than one you
shot the are they shooting now now he's
casting alright nothing but again Wow
let me hear from now yeah you know
principal photography is 100 days post
Wow [ __ ] here from now we're
literally gonna have a new music school
who the [ __ ] ever would have been a
million years thought that was what else
we're going to have we will have got
this September
maybe October don't know what the
premiere date is but the gifted is Fox's
x-men show from Bryan Singer and Burn
Notice career Matt Nick's like Burn
Notice yeah i watch the season one all
season one really and what is it this is
the theme get the gifted aka the
untitled uncle in x-men marvel drama
revolves on ER so call it the x-men it's
been here four years
why won't they call it the x-men marvel
drama not allowed to I'm not entirely
sure whether there's some kind of TV
features thing and Marvel might still
have the rights to the x-men for
animation on TV so maybe it's old [ __ ]
rights issue anyway it's the x-men it
revolves on a suburban couple played by
Amy Acker who's amazing and Steven Moya
from True Blood
who's ordinary lives are rocked but it's
done discovery that the children possess
mutant powers and they are forced to go
on the run from a hostile government
family I'm chase done anything I don't
believe so I think it's just they were
able to kind of pick and choose and as
long as we get mutants we can move
forward exactly why not and it gonna be
on TV it's gonna be on the Fox great
no more like lots make a bunch [ __ ] boom
finally five family run everything is
Guardian today uh what else here uh the
last member of our x-men Trinity is
Deadpool everyone loves dead everybody
loves at that tool you know who's gonna
get to love it even more TV viewers you
know why they're making uh and I made it
show on FXX
boy they better hand that to somebody
who knows a thing or two about comic
books let me tell you if it's all order
Deadpool so I'm not gonna just trust
anybody to handle this animation who's
in charge mark lando calrissian what I
got a gig to do a geek one of those
giddy
these geeks on the planet dog-lover
Donald Glover is going to executive
produce and show run along with his
brother Stephen you guys really belong
with us here among the cloud indeed yeah
ten episodes going to launch in 2018
there they got the writers room set up
in London
go on FXX and going XX word is they're
big fans of Archer and they approached
FXX and said we'd like to do this here
in FXX was like okay yeah and gentle
Orville and an FXX thing well you know
Fox has the rights I know but there's
never been nor eclis there's been a real
right now
but Jeph Loeb was like hey I love visit
lambda show you're really smart you're a
nerd do you like Deadpool and the archer
animation and the archer animation those
guys are super [ __ ] smart yeah so
yeah bang bang bang with bang bang good
idea man it's good idea um God he's busy
that dude yeah he works a lot
Dizzy's in homecoming yeah he's gonna be
in lando calrissian yeah
and now Atlanta season 2 he might have
another how this can't be no action damn
it
okay it's either him or Michael Green
out of the best year they're [ __ ] the
hardest-working man in show business
all right [ __ ] there it is a Deadpool
series I wonder hold voice you want to
just give Ryan Reynolds and Terrell do
it they absolutely could I bet you do I
mean why not he [ __ ] did the
voiceover for the honest trailer like
the same for the screen jug he's a good
guy think he's got a good sense of humor
mmm it's conceivable ah there it is
that's the million lot sex news laughter
you like to stand out there but work
meantime I thought we got from man come
back next episode we all do stuff what
kind of stuff one no lawyer [ __ ] we are
rated and we will have seen some [ __ ] by
then yeah we'll be able to drop down on
inside and so come back next episode
talk to me and Mark narnun here in the
Batcave Batman Batman Kevin said I am
NOT Kevin Smith he's Mark Bernard there
you go uh-huh yeah everyone's you think
about yeah just come back next episode
till then come back next episode [ __ ]
wash same pattern
come back next episode same bat-time
same bat-channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com / Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]